bringing it to the screen was definitely
a trying thing and was tiring in its own
ways definitely a very different
experience in the show you're living the
whole story every night so there's a lot
of sweat and mucus and spit and sorry
this is gross but it's true
[Music]
hi there i'm ben platt and this is how i
became evan hansen
[Music]
you know initially when we were creating
the character in the early days of the
musical and the readings um one of my
priorities was always to find the humor
in evan i think
a lot of that was accomplished by steven
levenson who's a brilliant writer who
wrote both the book of the musical and
the screenplay but i think because evan
is a pretty morally ambiguous like
somewhat of an anti-hero and he does
things that are difficult to get behind
sometimes i i think
it's important to find moments for him
to be have a levity and a humor and some
moments of lightness to help people kind
of get on his side so that when all of
the deeper more emotional kind of
heavier moments uh and sequences happen
they're they're earned and it's not just
consistently sort of playing that that
emotional heaviness and a lot of that
comes from you know my own awkwardness
and and kind of
exaggerating and emphasizing that and my
you know my
non-confrontational habits if you will
um and just sort of self-effacing humor
that is natural to evan
dear evan hansen today is going to be an
amazing day and here's why
[Music]
have you been doing those letters to
yourself with dr sherman i've been
trying to it's been
really incredible very unique kind of
once in a lifetime journey to take evan
all the way from the first ever reading
of the musical to the film version we
started in very early stages doing
several readings and workshops in new
york where it was a lot about finding
the the themes of the piece and the
bigger questions of the show and evan
was kind of like the backdrop for that
um and it became about these bigger
questions and i think as we got closer
to production to our first show in
washington dc which is where we first
put the musical up um i think a really
important switch that kind of happened
with the writers with the creative team
was realizing that it needed to be a
very specific story about evan hansen
this character and his experience and
his specific journey with all of these
greater questions and themes as his
backdrop rather than the reverse because
i think it made things much more human
and connected and
kind of relatable and obviously when we
got to our first production in dc i was
able to kind of really physicalize him
for the first time and find his kind of
posture and his the way that he sort of
looks to the ground whenever he can
avoids eye contact and fidgets with his
clothes and with his hands and to slowly
find how he comes alive physically
and then we got to do it off-broadway
and these things all got to progress and
i also got to get a little bit of
experience with
sustaining the performance eight times a
week and
recreating it as many times as i needed
to and then finally broadway it was just
all about
fine-tuning and just um
you know picking apart what exactly was
working and what we didn't need and what
was extra and what was necessary and
finding that performance that kind of
became the performance that i did for
about a year on broadway and then i got
to leave behind for a few years and come
back to it as a film project and
figure out which instincts that i wanted
to use from my past with the character
to bring back in and which instincts
felt like they made sense for the film
and also which things needed to be
stripped away or reinvented or made more
spontaneous and new for the for the film
version have you ever felt like you
could disappear dear evan hansen yeah
yeah that's mine i'll i'll just take it
wait i really i need that back
it's been wonderful working with benj
and justin for all these years i was a
huge fan of their music when i was in
high school they were like the cool
musical theater contemporary guys i used
to watch their videos on youtube and i
auditioned for their musical dogfight
that they did when i was 17 years old
and i was too young but um i immediately
connected with them and i think they saw
something in me and kept me in mind and
then brought me back around for evan
hansen and so to get to watch them you
know even before la la land and greatest
showman and you know all these things
that have happened since you know when i
first started working with them they
were just really strictly musical
theater guys and to watch them you know
have such a understanding and respect
and love of the musical theater form and
really reinvent it for the for the
contemporary audience in a way that i
don't think any other
composing team has in a long time um was
really exciting and to get to be the
voice of of that character and and
introduce so many of those songs into
the zeitgeist was very special and then
to re uh to re-attack with them now on
the film having you know seen them make
a number of films that were hugely
successful now and they're it's all very
old hat to them now and they're you know
these big guys and just to watch that
rise and then to work with them again on
the film and see that they're very much
the same people they were at the way
beginning um it was really special you
need a friend to carry you connor wanted
you to have this and when you're broken
on the ground dear evan hansen he wrote
it to you his last awards conor took his
own life
[Music]
in terms of the physical i really wanted
to
bring myself as close to the picture
that i have of evan in my head as i
could in a way that is somewhat healthy
and sustainable so i lost about 18
pounds doing like fitbit walks i did 14
000 steps a day for like a month um and
i did a fun diet where i was eating like
lean proteins and veggies and nuts and
not much else i grew my hair out and let
it go curly and jewish like it wants to
and i shaved my face multiple times a
day because i'm a jew again and my hair
grows fast i shaved my arms too to get a
little more kind of youth in my when i'm
wearing the polo and my t-shirts and
stuff and i you know tried to tap back
into some of the posture stuff and the
ticks and the the sort of nervous
movements from the broadway show
but try to translate them and sort of
demodulate them so that they would work
on camera and feel a little bit more
close to the ground a little more
authentic of a kid you might actually
find in these hallways of the school or
in someone's house or just just make it
as real as possible bringing it to the
screen
was definitely a trying thing and was
tiring in its own ways definitely a very
different experience in the show you're
living the whole story every night so
there's a lot of sweat and mucus and
spit and sorry this is gross but it's
true that just builds up and that you
have to let let let go and let come out
because it's a very visceral experience
to do something live in theater
um so in terms of that literal physical
experience obviously the film had a bit
of relief because i wasn't having to
live the entire story every day
and i was only having to attack each
sequence for like a day or two at a time
and really focus on one thing at a time
um the thing that i think was the more
challenging in the film
was expressing all of the emotion and
the kind of visceral you know effect of
that performance and trying to to bring
that same essence of something that
feels
you know very alive and and a little bit
overwhelming without
playing to the back of the house or
pushing beyond what a film needs and
just relying on the fact that i i didn't
need to work as hard to communicate the
same things and that i could really reel
it back back and
still have emotional moments and still
have those big you know outpourings of
emotion and of tears and song um without
such a histrionic um kind of energy that
is necessary for the stage and have it
still feel just as effective um so this
is kind of a learning curve
[Music]
i wish everything was different wish i
was part of something i wish that
anything i said mattered i think all
that playing evan for the camera was a
lot about only keeping the most
necessary components of the performance
alive so you know whereas on stage i
maybe had three or four different ticks
and a very exaggerated hunch and a
constant sort of tugging on my shirt and
a
um you know uh a lot of different
devices to communicate the same thing i
think on camera
a much more nuanced kind of palette
would suffice so
just a slight you know difference in
posture one or two moments of you know
nail-biting anxiety a little more of an
internal panic rather than external
panic things like that just really
turning the volume down but keeping the
intention uh and the characterization
the same and then in terms of the
singing on stage you can kind of get
away with a lot more theatricality um
and a lot more presentational singing
whereas i think in this film one of the
things it does most successfully is that
all the singing stays
very real and grounded and close to the
ground and and authentic and it was much
more about
feeling like a continuation of the scene
rather than stopping to perform a number
i'm putting together a memorial service
if you wanted to do something
connor showed me that i wasn't alone
nobody is
so
let that lonely feeling wash away
maybe there's a reason to believe you'll
be okay so the ulb found sequence in the
film was one of the more
um
familiar
settings and and more comfortable
settings for me because it is uh
within the show itself it is a
performance because he is speaking at
this memorial service for conor murphy
so just like in the broadway show i was
on a stage i had a microphone there was
a whole crowd of people uh the all of
the external elements were very familiar
so the the only
shift again had to be like an internal
one of knowing that even though this is
a house full of people i still only need
to communicate just this far to the lens
as opposed to to the whole crew so
you know as evan goes through the same
moment of panic where he drops the cards
and that whole sequence of kind of real
tension and suspense is still there but
i think that the outward manifestation
of the panic attack it was able to be a
lot smaller and closer to the ground and
still achieve the same thing
and then singing the song was just as
powerful for me as it was on stage
particularly because we had extras at
the memorial service who were fans of
evan hansen and who it meant so much to
them to be part of the film and to be
there oftentimes
extras don't even really know what it is
the project that they're doing and
there's sort of a an apathy that works
really well for for naturalistic acting
but something about having these kids
there in the audience who were emotional
and crying and witnessing it in person
and feeling the importance of that
reminded me of the experience of the
show and i think made it very special on
camera i didn't know that you were hurt
because when you don't feel strong
[Music]
a lot of people feel like us you can't
reach
reach out your head
i think the fact that this story
resonates so deeply with people
particularly young people is kind of the
overall overarching goal and reason why
i wanted to do the film i i had a lot of
personal reservations and worries and
fears and hesitations about re-entering
this material and kind of putting myself
emotionally through the ringer again in
this regard and trying to look like a
child again and all this stuff that
isn't in theory you know the healthiest
for me as a person but it's so
overridden by
the idea that
hundreds and thousands hopefully
millions of young people can see the
story in the film form
so quickly and and and so many more will
get to see it than would ever have just
seen it on stage and it just it creates
a real responsibility i think that we
all felt what we were shooting of really
getting it right particularly the
conversation around mental health and
making sure that we aren't doing
something that's trite or that's kind of
like
you know therapy bites that don't really
mean anything but that is a real
complicated human story that that really
acknowledges that every young person
struggles in some way and that
everybody's different and everybody has
sort of their snowflake mental health
issue and that there's no blanket answer
for any of that but that everybody feels
that so that we should really revel in
the connection of the fact that everyone
is going through some version of that
have you ever felt like
nobody was there um no one signed your
cast
now we can both pretend we are friends
being evan hansen
it's hard for me to really express what
that means to me because it has really
changed my life in every regard it
brought me closer to my partner my
boyfriend which is separately a really
beautiful thing it you know opened all
the career professional doors i've ever
dreamed of opening and i won a tony
award and i got to originate a role on
broadway and sing original pascan palm
music and you know i got to meet beyonce
and hillary clinton and all these heroes
of mine that came to see the show and
now i've gotten to be in this beautiful
major motion picture because of it um
and all of that is amazing but i think
above all else what it means to me is
that i get to be kind of a
representation for people particularly
young people of
of otherness and of anxiety which is
something i struggle with myself and of
the message that loneliness is not a
lonely experience meaning that everybody
feels lonely and that even the strange
sort of sidelined snerdy lonely kid is
worthy of his own narrative and is
worthy of taking the center of the stage
and being the focus and the fact that
that's the character for which i've you
know gotten some success and and have
become known to people is really special
and meaningful to me i mean you're
really gonna tell these people that the
only thing they have left of their son
was a letter that you wrote to yourself
so you and connor tell us something
please right um i started talking to you
couldn't stop they didn't want me to
stop i think that specificity sort of
begets universality generally and so i
think the the more
idiosyncratic and strange and individual
that i could make him in terms of his
mannerisms and his humor and the way
that he can't communicate and the way he
dresses with our costume designers both
on stage and on screen everything about
him that really brings him into focus i
think that's what makes him so
universally relatable i think if you try
to sort of wash a character out
in the name of people finding themselves
in the character it sort of counteracts
that because there's nobody that they
can place in their minds that seems like
this kind of a human being
whereas things that details that you
know on the surface maybe bring him
further from individuals like people who
are older than him or who are women or
who are trans or non-binary or people
that have nothing to do with the literal
manifestation of evan hansen i think the
realer and more specific of a person he
is the easier it is to find that you
share the same struggles as him whether
that's your anxiety your loneliness your
feeling of being trapped in your mind
rather than in the present with the
people around you
um
yeah i think they're going hand in hand
[Music]
if you knew who i am
just how broken i am
[Music]
i already know you
and i love you i i never like to preempt
emotion i think you should go on
whatever journey you want to go on when
you see this film if it's you know if it
doesn't resonate it doesn't resonate i
think it will but you never know
maybe bring some tissues just in case
i do think in a beautiful way that the
film is a little less
painful of an experience than the
musical both are beautiful experiences
worth having
but the musical is so visceral because
the people are in person that are going
through these things and these losses
and these these lies so there's
something really heavy about that which
is very powerful and why the musical
works but i think something about the
separation of film allows those things
to still be powerful and still be
emotional but sit a little easier on
your heart so i think it's a nice
balance people started sharing it it's
everywhere
i don't understand what happened
you did
you don't know how much you've given my
family and me
my favorite change well there's two
changes that i love in evan hansen one
is about the character of alana and how
much more fully developed she is in the
film and the song that she gets but the
other is the third act of the film once
evan has confessed
his lie to the family we get to actually
see
some time pass and really see in a very
specific way how evan moves forward how
he takes responsibility very publicly
for what he's done how he works to
really get to know conor and really do
the work to understand him after having
lied about knowing him
and how he is in some ways forgiven and
in some ways is not forgiven and how
that's okay to not to live somewhere in
the middle and i think that when we get
to that final scene and there's some
redemption it's not that it isn't earned
in the musical because there's the
things that you can achieve in a musical
are just very different than on film but
with characters that are so fully
realized like in this film i think it
was necessary to really feel that he
earns that redemption in the end and i i
think with flying colors you really feel
that in the film version i'm very proud
of that were you ever actually friends
with him
i never meant to make it such a mess i
was trying to help
my favorite moment in the show on
broadway
is probably if i could tell her which is
the song that uh evan sings to zoe where
he's using connor's he's making up
things that connor said about zoe as a
way to kind of subliminally tell her how
he feels about her and in the musical i
loved it because the beginning of the
show is very
kind of haphazard and there's lots of
big emotional numbers one after the
other waving through a window and then
four forever and then we have the big
high energy sincerely me just kind of go
go go and the first time that me as an
actor was able to just take a breath and
and have a moment to just sing something
a little bit calmer and less intense
and and take stock of where i am was if
i could tell her when i would sing that
with laura dreyfus every night and that
was just a moment that i always look
forward to and in the film i got to do
with caitlyn deiver who's a brilliant
next generation meryl streep and you
heard it here first but i loved it
because we were in a real kitchen and
really relating to each other and the
the song had to feel
even more naturalistic and authentic
because we were you know in such a real
setting and playing such real people
um and i just loved kind of dosing doing
around that kitchen island as you'll see
in the film with caitlin and singing to
her it's a really wonderful day
i have to tell them
i can confidently say that this will be
the very last time that i ever play evan
hansen or any teenage person for that
matter and what a way to go out
you